JJ BEHRENS: Hi.
My name is JJ Behrens.
I'm a developer advocate
at Google.
In this episode of Dartisans,
I'm going to show you a
variety of ways to use Dart
with Google Web Toolkit.
I know that there are a lot of
good developers out there who
would like to give Dart a shot,
but they can't, because
they already have a large
successful app
that's written in GWT.
I'm going to show you ways to
integrate Dart into your
existing GWT application without
having to rewrite it
from scratch.
If you'd like to download the
sample code, the URL is
bit.ly/dart_with_gwt.
To do this, I've built a simple
application that uses
both GWT and Dart.
I'll show you how to set up a
development environment so
that you can work with
both technologies.
Then I'll show you a variety of
ways in which you can get
GWT and Dart to interoperate,
such as using GWT and Dart to
manage different parts of the
same page; using Dart to
retrieve JSON from a
Java servlet; using
window.postMessage and JSNI to
pass messages between GWT and
Dart; using JavaScript, JSNI,
and Dart's js package for
synchronous interoperability
between GWT and Dart; using
CustomEvent objects and
Elemental to pass messages
between GWT and Dart.
Rather than show you a one
size fits all solution, I
decided to show you a bunch of
approaches so that you could
pick the right tool
for the job.
Each of them have strengths and
weaknesses, and I'll cover
those along the way as well.
By the way, this video is
best viewed full screen.
Also, be sure to set the
YouTube player to
play at 720p HD.
Let's quickly cover how I set up
my development environment.
I used Eclipse and Dart Editor
to build the simple
application.
If you're a GWT developer,
you're probably already very
familiar with how to install
Eclipse, so I won't
bore you with that.
The GWT website has some pretty
decent instructions.
I used the Juno release of the
Eclipse IDE for Java EE
developers.
Then I installed the Google
plugin for Eclipse.
I decided to install everything,
but the most
important things are Google
Web Toolkit and Google App
Engine Java SDK.
The instructions also walk you
through installing Google Web
Toolkit developer plug-in
for Chrome.
To install Dart, head on
over to dartlang.org.
If you've never installed Dart
Editor before, there's even a
getting started guide.
I like to use Dart and various
other tools from the command
line, so I have the following
in my bashrc.
Of course, you can also rely
on Dart Editor to run those
tools for you.
Dart Editor is based on Eclipse
components, so it kind
of looks like a very stripped
down version of Eclipse.
You might be wondering why I
don't use the Dart Editor
plug-in for Eclipse.
Unfortunately, it's not yet as
polished as Dart Editor is.
I recommend keeping Dart Editor
separate of Eclipse for
the time being, until things
settle down and a few
key bugs get fixed.
Using Eclipse to edit Java and
Dart Editor to edit Dart
actually works out pretty
well for me.
You could still use Eclipse
with the EGit plug-in to
commit your Dart files to Git,
but I tend to use the command
line to interact with Git
anyway, because that's where
I'm most comfortable.
Let's start by creating
a GWT application.
Then you'll embed a Dart
application within it.
Finally, I'll show how to use
GWT and Dart to manage
different parts of
the same page.
Since GWT and Dart each have
their own requirements for how
the application should be laid
out, I'm going to start by
creating a GWT application.
So I'm going to come
here and select New
Web Application Project.
I'm going to call it GWT
Application, because I'm kind
of a creative guy.
I'll put it in
org.land.gwtapplication, and
leave it in my workspace.
I am going to use Google Web
Toolkit and Google App Engine,
and that's it.
So I'll go ahead and
finish that.
So here's an application, and
it has a war directory.
The war directory is where all
the static files go, so that's
where my Dart application's
going to go.
I'm going to create the
Dart application
from within Dart Editor.
So I'm going to create
a new application.
I'm going to call it Dart
Application, and you can see
here that it's within the
war directory of my GWT
application.
I'll include sample content and
make it a web application,
and hit Finish.
Now, I like the project layout
that Dart Editor set up for
me, but I don't need the CSS
file, and I don't need this
HTML file, and I'm going to
delete most of the start file.
So I'm going to go ahead and
do that really quickly.
By the way, if you're
using Git, here's
my Git ignore file.
Now I'm going to get rid of most
of the sample code that
Eclipse created.
You have to do it in the right
order, or you'll get errors.
Remember to delete the reference
to the servlet in
web.XML, or else the app
won't start correctly.
I'm also going to mostly empty
out the GWT application class.
Now all I'm left with is an
empty on module load method in
the GWT application.Java file.
Now let's fire up the GWT
application in Eclipse.
I'm going to select debug as
web application, and select
GWTapplication.html.
And this takes a few seconds
to start up,
and there's the URL.
If I double click on it,
it starts in Chrome.
Of course, there's not
much there right now.
If you haven't yet installed the
Google Web Toolkit plug-in
for Chrome, it'll walk you
through that at this point.
By the way, if you downloaded
the source code for the sample
project, and you're trying to
get it to work, remember that
to run the Dart code, you need
to either use Dartium, that
is, the copy of Chromium that
comes with Dart Editor--
or you need to compile the code
to JavaScript using Dart
to JS, which, again, can be
done with Dart Editor.
It's a common mistake to try
to run the code in regular
Chrome before you've compiled
the Dart to JavaScript.
That won't work yet.
I should also mention that
although GWT's development
mode works for most of the
code in this tutorial, it
doesn't yet work
for Elemental.
So if you've downloaded the
sample code, you'll need to
actually compile it and strip
off the GWT code server
parameter before you can
view the application.
Now let's edit the HTML file
in the war directory.
First, I'll get rid of most of
the comments so that it's
easier to see what's going on.
Now I'm going to tweak the title
and the H1 for the page.
Now I'm going to get rid
of this HTML here.
Notice that I've used an H2 for
the GWT section and an H2
for the Dart section, and I've
also created a div for the GWT
section and a div for the Dart
section, and I could plug into
these from the GWT and the
Dart code respectively.
Now I'm going to add
two script tags.
The first one is my
DartApplication.dart file, and
then the second one is the
standard dart.js file.
Now, this dart.js file is
responsible for seeing it's a
browser support start, and if
it does, everything's good.
If it doesn't, it loads the
corresponding JavaScript
version of my
DartApplication.dart file.
The dart.js file actually gets
created by pub, Dart's package
manager, thanks to
our dependence
on the browser package.
Now let's do Hello World in
GWT by having GWT print
something to the page.
I've added a vertical panel
to the GWT div.
I've also created a print string
method that can add new
labels to the vertical panel.
Let's try it out.
I reloaded the page in Chrome,
and now it says GWT
application loaded.
Great.
GWT is now interacting
with the HTML page.
Now let's do the same
thing in Dart.
Let's edit the
DartApplication.dart file that
lives deep within GWT's
war directory.
However, let's edit
it in Dart Editor.
First, I query for the Dart
div, then I create a print
string method like
I did for GWT.
Notice the cool method cascade
syntax that saves me from
writing div two times.
Also notice that I'm setting the
text property of the div
element rather than the
inner HTML property.
That way, I don't have to
worry about cross site
scripting attacks.
Now I can call print string to
say that the Dart application
has loaded.
At this point, I could compile
the Dart to JavaScript.
However, during development,
it's much faster to run the
code in Dartium.
I'm going to copy the URL from
Chrome, and then come over
here to my Dart Editor
directory, where I have Dart
Editor, and click on Chromium.
Now, this is actually Dartium,
and it understands Dart
natively, and so it's going
to run the code natively.
And there we go.
It says Dart application
loaded.
So Dart is interacting
with the HTML page.
Furthermore, you could see that
Dart and GWT are both
running on the same page at
the same time, managing
different parts of
the same page.
Later, I'll show you how they
could work even more closely.
Now is a great time for me to
show you how to debug your
code in Dart Editor.
Even though the code is being
served from a web server
running in Eclipse, you
could still debug the
code in Dart Editor.
I just need to create a custom
launch configuration with the
correct URL.
So I'll come up here and
manage launches.
I already got rid of all the
other launch configurations,
so I'm going to create a
new one with Dartium.
I'll call it Dartium.
And here's the URL
that we used.
We got this from our
Chrome launch.
And we'll run in checked
mode, and so forth.
And we need to pick the project,
which is, of course,
Dart application.
And I'll go ahead
and run that.
Great.
This time, I'm going to set a
breakpoint in the editor.
And I'm going to go ahead
and run that again.
And it dumps me immediately back
into Dart Editor, and you
can see my various variables.
I'll go ahead and step over
the code a little bit.
So we have a Dart div,
window, and so forth,
and here's my stack.
And so you can see that I can
debug my Dart code from within
Dart Editor.
Another thing that I could do is
come over here to generate
JavaScript.
And that's going to compile my
Dart to JavaScript, and then I
can go over to Chrome, then,
from within Chrome, I'll
select Tools, Developer Tools.
Click on the gear icon here, and
I will enable source maps.
Great, that's done already.
And then come over
here to sources--
I'll have to get rid of
this real quick--
and then I could pick from here
the DartApplication.dart.
And notice, this is Chrome.
It doesn't actually
understand Dart.
But because of source
maps, it's able to
show me the Dart code.
And from here, I'm even able to
set break points and debug
it from within Chrome.
If you're using GWT, it's very
likely you have Java on the
server side, too.
Hence, it's important that your
Dart code be able to talk
to your Java code
on the server.
If you're used to using GWT, you
may be accustomed to using
GWT RPC to talk to your
Java servlets.
Unfortunately, that's not
an option for Dart.
The protocol is very specific
to GWT and Java.
However, you could certainly
generate JSON using your Java
servlet, and then consume that
JSON from Dart using an XML
HTTP request.
It's not as slick as GWT RPC,
but it definitely works.
Let me show you how
to do that.
Here's the code for a servlet
that serves JSON.
In this code, I'm hard
coding the JSON.
But naturally, you could
generate the JSON dynamically
using a JSON library.
In order to make use of
JSONservlet.java, you have to
edit web.xml, and tie
the servlet to a
particular HTTP path.
This requires a servlet tag
and a servlet mapping tag.
Notice the URL that I used.
Let's restart the application
and check to make sure that
the servlet is actually
generating the JSON correctly.
I could view that
URL in Chrome.
Good.
It looks like the application is
generating JSON correctly.
Now let's look at
DartApplication.dart in Dart Editor.
I use HTTP request dot get
string to fetch a URL.
Rather than take a call back,
it returns a future object.
I register a success handler
using the then method, and an
error handler using the
catch error method.
The use of futures is pretty
pervasive in Dart, both on the
client side as well as the
server side, so this code will
look familiar if you're
a Dart developer.
In this code, I'm just
printing out the JSON
response, but it's trivial to
parse it using the Dart colon
JSON library.
Now that we've covered getting
Dart to talk to your Java
server, let's cover how
to get Dart and GWT
to talk to one another.
One approach that HTML5 provides
for getting different
things to talk to each
other in a browser is
window.postMessage.
You could use window.postMessage
for lots of
things, such as communicating
with your C code written using
[INAUDIBLE], or getting webpages
from different
domains to communicate.
It's also one way of getting
Dart and GWT
to talk to one another.
They could simply pass messages
back and forth.
However, since GWT doesn't
have native support for
window.postMessage, I'll need to
use JSNI, GWT's JavaScript
native interface.
In the following, I'm going to
show you six pieces of code.
How to call postMessage from GWT
and then from Dart; how to
listen for postMessage from GWT
and then from Dart; and
how to create a button to
generate a postMessage from
GWT and then from Dart.
Once it's all done, I'll show it
to you with all the pieces
working together.
First, let me show you how to
call postMessage from GWT.
This requires JSNI, the
JavaScript native
interface for GWT.
I create a method called
postMessage that takes a
string message.
Notice that I use the
native keyword.
The body of the method is a
weird mix of JavaScript and
JSNI hidden in a comment.
In order to call
window.postMessage, I have to
call dollar wnd dot
postMessage.
Now let me show you how to call
postMessage from Dart.
Hmm, well, that's not
very exciting.
Now let me show you
how to listen for
message events in GWT.
Let's start by calling a new
method called listen for
postMessage in on module load.
Now I have to implement listen
for postMessage.
Just like before, this requires
JSNI, which is why I
had to pull the code for listen
for postMessage out of
on module load and into
its own method.
The key part is window dot add
event listener, where we
listen for message events.
That takes a call back.
Notice that I have to set
var that equals this.
This is a little JavaScript
trick that's necessary because
of a weird scoping issue
in JavaScript.
Inside the add event listener,
there's a really long piece of
code that has a fully qualified
class name.
This is the JSNI code
necessary to
call back into Java.
I call from JavaScript into my
on post message, which is a
simple Java method.
The nice thing is that JSNI
takes care of casting the data
to the right types when calling
on postMessage.
Inside on postMessage, I just
print a string saying that GWT
has received a postMessage.
Here's how to listen for
postMessage in Dart.
Once again, Dart provides an
API, so it's pretty easy.
I just call window dot on
message dot listen,
and pass a call back.
Notice the convenient function
expression syntax, the use of
triple quotes, and the use
of string interpolation.
Now let's create a
button in GWT.
Clicking on the button will
send a postMessage.
This code is fairly
straightforward.
It just calls the postMessage
method that we wrote earlier.
Now let's look at the Dart code
to do the same thing.
I create a new button element,
and set some properties on it.
I add the GWT button class to
it to make sure it looks the
same as the button
I created in GWT.
My on click listener just calls
window.postMessage directly.
Now let's see if everything
works.
First, I'll restart the
server just in case.
Then I'll hit reload
in Dartium.
I click on each of the buttons,
first to generate a
postMessage from GWT, and
then to generate a
postMessage from Dart.
Notice that it doesn't matter
who sends the postMessage.
Both sides receive it.
That's just something you have
to keep in mind when you use
postMessage the way
we're using it.
From the browser's perspective,
there's no
difference between whether
Dart or GWT is calling
window.postMessage.
By the way, I'm kind of ignoring
the origin of the
postMessage.
You could read more about
postMessage online to learn
about the security implications
of properly
checking the origin.
But that's outside the scope
of this tutorial.
Window.postMessage is a useful
tool to have in your toolbox,
because it can work in a variety
of situations, as I
mentioned earlier.
However, since Dart and GWT
both have an API for
JavaScript interoperability, you
could use JavaScript as an
intermediary between
Dart and GWT.
They can even synchronously
call each other's methods.
This lets you do very fine
grained interoperability.
However, this fine grained
interoperability
comes with a cost.
First of all, using Dart's JS
package can almost double the
size of the generated
JavaScript for Dart.
In my sample, it made the
JavaScript 89% larger.
Secondly, because Dart can run
natively in Dartium, and
because doing distributed
garbage collection across two
virtual machines is nontrivial,
using the JS
package to integrate with
JavaScript and Dart requires a
little more work than in other
languages that always compile
the JavaScript.
Rather than show you how to put
a single callback function
on the window object, I'm
going to show you how to
create a JavaScript module so
that you could have lots of
callback functions.
Hence, I'm going to show
you four things--
how to create a JavaScript
module and a callback function
in GWT, and then in Dart, how to
call the Dart callback from
GWT, and how to call the
GWT callback from Dart.
Just like I did for postMessage,
I'll create a
button on each side that the
user can click on in order to
invoke the callbacks.
First, let's start with GWT.
In on module load, I'll call
a new method, init GWT
application module.
Init GWT application module
is implemented using JSNI.
I set window dot GWT application
module to a new
JavaScript object that
contains a single
method, GWT call back.
GWT call back is a JavaScript
method that calls a Java
method that is also called
GWT call back.
Hence, with just a little bit
of JSNI code, I've set up a
JavaScript module where I could
add as many call backs
as I need, and I can implement
those call backs using Java.
To make it even more realistic,
the GWT callback
method takes three parameters.
An int, a string, and
a JavaScript object.
I did this to show you that Dart
and GWT can pass complex
JavaScript objects back and
forth to each other.
Finally, the GWT callback
method returns a string.
There's another interesting
thing to notice.
The Java version of GWT callback
receives a JavaScript
object passed from Dart
instance, rather than a
JavaScript object instance.
This is based on GWT's notion
of JavaScript overlay types.
The JavaScript object passed
from Dart class extends
JavaScript object, and it adds
a hello method implemented in
JSNI, so that the Java code can
interact more easily with
the JavaScript object
passed from Dart.
As a final comment, unlike with
postMessage, where the
message was asynchronous and
went to everyone listening for
messages, in this case, the call
back is synchronous, only
goes to a single listener, and
even has a return value.
Nonetheless, the implementation
isn't too
different from the code we
used for postMessage.
Over on the Dart side, the code
looks very different.
First, I have to add the JS
package as a dependency in my
pubspec.yaml.
Dart Editor recognizes when I
change pubspec.yaml and will
automatically run Pub Install
for me to update my
dependencies.
If it doesn't, you
can always select
Tools, Reanalyze Sources.
Next, I have to add some code
in DartApplication.dart.
I start by importing the JS
package using the prefix JS.
Now, let's look at the
code for setting up
the JavaScript module.
In this code, JS.context is
basically a reference to the
JavaScript window object.
I create a new JavaScript object
using JS.map, and I
assign it to JS.context.darta
pplicationmodule.
Then, inside the JavaScript
object, I create a new
callback called Dart Callback
that references a Dart
function that is also called
Dart Callback.
Notice that Dart's JavaScript
interoperability API doesn't
let you sling little bits of
JavaScript all over the place.
Furthermore, the API requires
that you be a little bit more
explicit about how memory
is managed.
For instance, notice that the
use of js.scoped which sets up
a memory context.
The Dart team did it this
way because dealing with
distributed garbage collection
when you have two entirely
separate VMs is a very
difficult problem.
On the other hand, the Dart
code is pure Dart.
It's easy to create a JavaScript
object using
JS.map, and it's easy to set up
a callback that will call
back into Dart using
JS.callback.
In this case, the callback might
be called many times
instead of just once, so I used
JS.callback.many rather
than JS.callback.once.
By the way, the astute reader
might be wondering if Dart has
JavaScript overlay types
like GWT does.
If you look at the Dart version
of Dart call back,
you'll see that Dart can
interact with a JavaScript
object without needing to create
a specific JavaScript
overlay type.
That's because Dart uses a
JS.proxy object to act as a
proxy object for the
JavaScript object.
This is very convenient, because
it lets you use a
JavaScript object as if it were
a native Dart object.
On the other hand, GWT's
JavaScript overlay types do
have one benefit.
They work very well with code
completion in Eclipse.
Code completion in Dart editor
isn't particularly helpful
with JS proxy objects, since
JS proxy is a dynamic proxy
which is based on Dart's
no such method feature.
Now let's look at how to call
the Dart call back from GWT.
Just like before, I set up a
button that the user can click
on in order to call
the call back.
This calls a JSNI method called
Call Dart Call Back,
which I'll create in
just a moment.
I can pass an int and a string
directly to Call Dart
Callback, but in order to create
a native JavaScript
object, I use another JSNI
method called Create Object
For Callback.
The Create Object For Callback
method is just a simple JSNI
method that just returns an
opaque JavaScript object.
Inside the method, you can see
that the JavaScript object
itself is very simple.
The Call Dart Callback method is
a JSNI method that takes an
int, a string, and the
JavaScript object that we've
created in Create Object
For Callback.
Then it calls window.dartappli
cationmodule.dartcallback,
which is pretty much how you'd
call the callback from
JavaScript.
Notice that Call Dart Callback
returns the string that is
returned by the Dart callback.
Now let's look at
the Dart code to
invoke the GWT callback.
Once again, I create
a button element.
This time, however, the
onclick.listen event handler
makes use of the JS library in
order to call JS.context.GWTap
plicationmodule.GWTcallback.
Remember that JS.context is
Dart's reference to JavaScript
window object.
I pass three parameters to the
GWT callback function--
an int, a string, and a
JavaScript object, which I
create with JS.map.
Finally, I print the result
of the callback.
OK, now that we have all the
code, let's try it out.
I'm going to call the Dart
callback from GWT, and the
Dart callback is called with
these parameters, and it says
that Dart received a callback,
which is the return value.
Now I'm going to call the
GWT callback from Dart.
And the GWT callback is called
with these parameters, and
Dart says that GWT received
the callback, which is the
return value.
It really is possible to get GWT
and Dart to talk to each
other synchronously, using
JavaScript as an intermediary.
The last approach I'm going
to show you is the
most leading edge.
Just like the section in which
I used window.postMessage to
send events between GWT and
Dart, you can also use custom
event objects.
However, this time, instead of
using JSNI to work with APIs
that GWT doesn't natively
support, I'll show you how to
use Elemental.
While I can't say that there was
actual blood involved in
developing this part of the
sample, I can't say that it
was pretty painful to be so
close to the bleeding edge.
There are a bunch of hurdles to
overcome, and there isn't
much documentation on Elemental,
or how to use
custom event objects
in GWT and Dart.
Elemental is a new library for
fast, lightweight, and to the
metal web programming in GWT.
It's intended for developers
who are comfortable working
with the browser APIs that
JavaScript programmers use.
Elemental is very convenient,
since it doesn't require you
to write any JSNI code.
However, it's still a fairly
new technology.
Not only is it woefully
underdocumented, but it's also
currently incompatible
with GWT's
development mode plug-in.
One approach is to switch to
super dev mode, which is an
experimental replacement
for GWT's
development mode plug-in.
However, there are currently
a lot of drawbacks to using
super dev mode.
After consulting with another
GWT developer at Google, I
opted for the safe, albeit
slow and painful route of
recompiling to JavaScript and
restarting the server every
time I make a change.
This works, although it does
put a cramp in your style.
Let's start on the GWT side
by setting up Elemental.
Elemental does come with GWT,
but to actually use it, you
have to copy the JAR
file from the SDK
bundle into your project.
I like to do this from
the command line.
First, I CD into my clips
directory, because I know the
SDK bundle is in there
somewhere.
Then, I find the JAR file.
Now I copy that file into GWT
application slash war slash
webINF slash lib.
Now I have to tell Eclipse to
make use of the new JAR file,
so I'm going to right click on
the project and hit refresh.
And then in the lib directory,
I'm going to find the GWT
elemental JAR file that I copied
over, right click on
that, and add it to
my build path.
Now I have to set up elemental
in the GWT application dot GWT
dot XML file.
All I have to do is say that
the module inherits from
Elemental.elemental.
At this point, it's not a bad
idea to clean the project, run
GWT compile, and restart
the server.
If you're following along,
remember that Elemental is
currently incompatible with
GWT's development mode.
So that not only means you'll
have to recompile the Java
code each time, I'm also going
to have to change the Dartium
launch configuration.
So I'm going to go here and
manage launch, click here, and
the key thing is that I need
to remove this parameter
called GWT code server.
So I'm going to apply
that and run that.
Great.
Things still work.
Another word of warning about
Elemental imports in GWT.
com.google.gwt and Elemental
each have separate APIs for
interacting with the browser.
Hence, there's a lot of
overlapping class names.
Pay close attention to where
you import classes from.
In this section, we'll
mostly be importing
classes from Elemental.
Now, here's the code to
generate a custom
event object in GWT.
Just like before, I create a
button that the user can click
on to generate the
custom event.
I create the custom event using
document.createevent
custom event, and I
cast the return
value to a custom event.
For the detail property, I
create a JSON object using
JSJSONobject.create.
Notice that I don't need
to use JSNI to create a
JavaScript object.
Then, I shove a bunch
of data into it.
Next, I call init custom event,
passing in the custom
event type and the
detail property.
I serialize the detail
object to JSON
using the to JSON method.
Finally, I call window
dot dispatch event.
By the way, it may be possible
to skip serialization to JSON,
but I wasn't able to get it to
work with Dart under both
Dartium and Dart to JS.
The code to listen for a custom
event is even more
straightforward.
It, too, is free of JSNI code.
I use add event listener
to listen for
the custom Dart event.
Then, in the event handler,
I cast the
event to a custom event.
I unpack the detail property
using JSON.parse.
After that, it's
smooth sailing.
Here's how to generate a custom
event object in Dart.
I create a normal Dart
map with all the data
that I want to pass.
Next, I create a custom event
using Dart's custom event
constructor.
I serialize the detail to JSON
using JSON.stringify.
Finally, I call
window.dispatchevent to
dispatch the custom event.
To listen for custom event
objects using the new streams
API, I start by creating an
event stream provider called
custom event stream provider.
You don't have to do this for
most types of events, but
custom events are,
well, custom.
Now I can listen for custom
events on the window object
using the custom event
stream provider
that I created earlier.
When I receive one, I unpack
the detail property using
JSON.parse.
JSON.parse returns a
normal Dart map.
After that, it's once again
smooth sailing.
To show everything working, I
need to compile the GWT to
JavaScript and restart
the server.
So I'm going to right click on
the GWT application, go to
Google, GWT compile, compile.
And now that that's done, I'm
going to restart the server.
Now, in Dartium, I could
generate a custom GWT event,
and Dart receives it.
And I can generate a custom
Dart event, and
GWT receives it.
Great.
Dartium's great, but let's
compile it to JavaScript so we
can run it in other browsers.
Here it is running in standard
Chrome, and here it is running
in Firefox.
The other buttons
work as well.
Great.
My work here is done.
I hope I've convinced you that
if you already have a large
GWT app, but you want to give
Dart a try, you shouldn't feel
like you have to rewrite
your whole app.
You can dip your toes in the
water to see if you like it.
By the way, here are a couple
of other projects that you
might be interested in, although
I haven't had a
chance yet to check them out.
As I was building this sample,
I made heavy use of the GWT
and Dart documentation, and I
kept a list of links that I
found particularly helpful.
You can check the transcript
for all the details.
Thanks for watching.
You can download the sample
source code and the transcript
for this video from
bit.ly/dart_with_gwt.
If you'd like to learn more
about Dart, check out
Dartlang.org.
And if you have any questions
about using Dart with GWT,
post them to Stack Overflow
using the tags Dart and GWT.
If you'd like to follow
me on Google+, here's
a link to my profile.